here's what would happen if Putin died
Russia would experience a power vacuum
not seen since the death of Joseph
Stalin in 1953 immediately Power would
transfer to prime minister mihail
mishusten this interim president would
rule for 90 days until the next election
if Putin didn't hand pick a successor
before passing a military official might
try to grab power this would be
dangerous putting Russia's Armed Forces
chemical weapons and nuclear Firepower
into even more unstable hands Russia is
one of the world's major oil exporters
so your gas prices would rise again we'd
need to figure out how to keep the
supply chain running after cutting
Russia off if harsh economic sanctions
remained on Russia conditions on the
ground could turn into an all-out
Rebellion the mounting pressure could
pull Russia out of Ukraine since it's
hard to wage war with no money so